qu'est-il arrivé à chucky
gee où diable es-tu tu es le
seul à qui je peux parler de ce qui
s'est vraiment passé
ça a été une année vraiment difficile
es-tu
aussi heureux que tu m'as rendu
[Musique]
qui est-ce
et pourquoi diable es-tu  vous appelez pour
vous assurer que vous êtes à la maison
cette croix mr evans et mr wheeler
savez-vous pourquoi vous êtes ici je connais votre
histoire
ce n'est qu'un chien
nous
encore
je déteste cette poupée
j'ai besoin de tiffany
pour obtenir ce qui lui arrive
aller à glinda viens voir maman
lâcher prise
chère douce marraine de je vous salue marie jesus
[musique]
salut
je suis chucky
veux prier
juste me regarder est assez effrayant pour
te donner  une crise cardiaque
oh mon dieu merci